année scolaire 1965 pour la première
fois les écoliers français ne sont pas
tous en vacances en même temps le pays
est alors divisé en deux zones pour les
vacances d'hiver de printemps mais aussi
celles d'été six ans plus tard en 1971
les zones de vacances passent ensuite
pour la première fois de deux à trois
zones à b et c un découpage qui vaudra
jusqu'au début des années 80 premiers
effets prévisibles de ces mesures
désengorger les autoroutes au début
juillet et sans doute réduire
l'hécatombe sur les routes le tourisme
devrait aussi profiter de l'étalement
des vacances
l'économie touristique profitera
effectivement de cet étalement des
vacances voulue par les gouvernements
successifs en décalant d'une semaine ou
deux les départs en vacances des
écoliers des différentes régions
l'arrivée sur les zones touristiques est
aussi étalé
résultat au lieu de deux semaines les
professionnels travaillent activement
pendant un mois un argument économique
au profit du rythme des enfants selon
cette association de parents d'élèves
mais nous pensons que ces mesures
répondent de plus aux exigences du
tourisme
départs en vacances dsm cf tous ces
problèmes plutôt que de l'impératif
pédagogique et nous pensons que ce nous
sommes que les mesures fragmentaire qui
ne résoudront pas le problème
les rythmes scolaires au cours des ans
le découpage des vacances scolaires
changera encore plusieurs fois en 1981
par exemple le gouvernement optait pour
un étalement des vacances à la carte
laissés au choix des 30 recteurs
d'académie une idée qui n'arrangeait pas
vraiment certains professionnels du
tourisme
le mauvais étalement des vacances se
traduit pour nous par une demande accrue
de passagers sur des jours de points que
nous ne pourrons pas écrêté c'est bien
évident sous la pression des
professionnels du tourisme le
gouvernement reviendra à trois zones de
vacances à partir de 1991
encore une fois des parents d'élèves
dénonçait la pression de l'économie
touristique et particulièrement celle de
l'or bleu basé l'essentiel des du
calendrier scolaire sur des activités
qui ne sont pas pratiqués 2 faites par
la grande majorité de nos élèves
c'est ne pas prendre en compte leur ont
pas leur offrir les meilleures
conditions pour réussir aujourd'hui les
zones de vacances sont toujours au
nombre de trois seule la répartition des
académies a changé depuis 2015 avec le
nouveau découpage des régions
[Musique]